existen los términos que seguramente han
escuchado en relación con el presupuesto
los préstamos y el gasto del gobierno
déficit y deuda ambos pueden confundirse
porque se asocian a préstamos y
presupuestos ambos comienzan con la
letra d y ambos están relacionados pero
significan cosas diferentes el déficit
se refiere a que se gasta más de lo que
se recibe desde el punto de vista del
gobierno éste puede referirse a que en
un año el gobierno gasta más de lo que
recibe como ingreso lo escribimos el
déficit es la diferencia entre lo que se
gasta y lo que se recibe durante ese año
o ciclo presupuestario por otra parte la
deuda se refiere a la cantidad total que
se debe pagar estos términos claramente
están relacionados vamos a analizar el
déficit y la deuda en miles de millones
de un gobierno imaginario durante cinco
años aquí ponemos el déficit y aquí la
deuda en el primer año se sobrepasó el
gasto en 200 mil millones suponiendo que
este país no tenía deuda antes de este
momento ahora tiene una deuda de 200 mil
millones de la moneda local para el
segundo año se tiene un déficit de 100
mil millones por lo
ahora debemos la cantidad anterior más
estos 100 mil millones es decir
trescientos mil millones en el tercer
año digamos que se gastó mucho más del
ingreso y el déficit es de 500 mil
millones esto se suma a la deuda por lo
que ahora se debe 800 mil millones las
deudas se pueden pagar y para pagar la
deuda se debe tener un superávit durante
el año podemos ver al superávit como un
déficit negativo imaginamos que para el
cuarto año el déficit negativo es de
menos 100 mil millones aunque
normalmente no nos referimos a esto como
un déficit negativo sino como un
superávit que tuvo el gobierno durante
ese año como se hizo un pago a la deuda
ahora la deuda es de 700 mil millones
también podemos tener años con balance
perfecto en donde no hubo ni déficit ni
superávit en cuyo caso la deuda
permanece igual algunos de ustedes
seguramente se preguntarán qué pasa con
los intereses pero los intereses de la
deuda son parte del presupuesto del
gobierno por lo que ya se consideran
aunque se tenga un déficit o un
superávit para que esto sea más claro
veremos un ejemplo usando datos del
gobierno de los estados
a continuación se muestra una gráfica
con los déficits y superávits en los
eeuu desde 1967 al año 2017 y también
muestra la predicción de una década en
el futuro aunque estas predicciones no
son definitivas y se deben tomar con
precaución las barras que van hacia
abajo indican los años en los que este
gobierno tuvo déficits y las barras que
van hacia arriba y mika los años en los
que hubo superávit que fueron los años
en el que el gobierno tuvo más ingresos
que gastos recuerden que los déficits y
los superávits se refieren a que tanto
se gastó de más o de menos durante
cierto año las deudas se refieren a la
cantidad acumulada de lo que se debe
pagar para visualizar mejor lo que es
una deuda veamos la siguiente gráfica
después está la deuda total acumulada
por año desde 1970 hasta años recientes
de los eeuu podemos ver que la deuda se
ha acumulado mucho durante estos años se
aproxima a los 24 billones de dólares
esto es lo que debe el gobierno de los
eeuu muchas personas argumentan que la
economía de eeuu ha aumentado mucho y lo
que importa es verla
como un porcentaje del pib que es lo que
vemos en la siguiente gráfica aquí la
deuda no se ve tan dramática pues la
deuda como porcentaje es casi igual al
pib de este país si hiciéramos una
analogía con lo que ocurre con un
individuo si esta persona tuviera un
ingreso de 100 mil pesos al año esto
sería como tener una deuda de 100 mil
pesos al año algo interesante es pensar
en los pros y los contras de tener un
déficit durante cierto año que se
agregue a la deuda que se tenga uno de
los argumentos a favor del déficit es
que permite al gobierno implementar
políticas fiscales contracíclicas o si
hay recesión entonces tener una política
fiscal expansiva de la cual hablamos en
otros vídeos y que a menudo involucra
disminuir los impuestos e incrementar
los gastos del gobierno lo que permite
al gobierno disminuir la severidad de la
recesión lo que será beneficioso a largo
plazo todo esto es debatible es muy
sencillo pensar en los contras uno es
que la deuda puede llegar a ser
insostenible hay ejemplos de países cuya
deuda creció tanto que no podían
siquiera pagar los intereses de esa
deuda recuerden que ya sean individuos
o países cuando se pide dinero prestado
hay que pagar intereses si la deuda es
muy grande los intereses pueden ser tan
altos que el gobierno ya no puede
pagarlos y aun cuando el país pueda
pagar los intereses el dinero usado para
pagarlos pudo haberse ocupado en otras
cosas más productivas otro contra de
tener déficits que incrementan la deuda
es que puede afectar a las tasas de
interés en todo el mercado puede
ocasionar un incremento en las tasas de
interés cuando estudiamos el mercado
monetario vimos que mientras más pida
prestado al gobierno más se va a
desplazar a la derecha la demanda de
dinero en el mercado y si aumenta la
tasa de interés entonces puede ocasionar
el efecto desplazamiento que mencionamos
en otros vídeos en el que debido al
incremento en las tasas de interés menos
prestatarios privados van a pedir
préstamos los cuales podrían haber sido
usados como inversiones en resumen lo
importante es no confundir estos
términos de déficit y deuda el déficit y
el superávit se refieren a cuánto se
gasta de más o de menos durante un año y
la deuda es la cantidad total que se
debe pagar con esto terminamos y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo